what's your thoughts on I'm curious
bringing when you're bringing these
c-suite Executives in what's your
thought on giving Equity was that
something you ever did absolutely so let
me tell you but by far from me so I
watch two companies like mine that sold
one of them sold in 91. 50 of the
company left and started their own
companies wow fifty percent of the
company left so when Sandy wow from
Citigroup bought the company half the
company left so it's like what the hell
just happened we just bought this
company and nobody is here and I have
the company left it took them two or
three years to recover don't feel bad
for them they still turn that 100
million dollar company into a seven
billion Auto Company okay they're doing
fine yeah the second company when it
sold in 01 half the company left okay so
similar problem now I have the benefit
of studying history they I'm grateful to
them because they set the Mark I can
learn from them right so I looked at
both of them and I said what did they do
right and what are some areas that I can
do differently when I started the
company I put out a guy line and I said
guys
if you do x y z because in 2007 remember
when Jerry Maguire came out yeah that
movie really inspired yeah yeah and I
made the mistake of writing a similar
type of a letter to 400 billion Auto
Company in the middle of the night I
send this letter 16 Pages at nine points
that was the downfall of me and that
company because they were not happy that
I had ideas and it was I send it in
first time around nobody responds back
then I send it to the company that owned
them 400 billion dollar company
everybody called These are great ideas
five people flew into meet me in Orange
County California and I met with them
but that's when I realized okay I just
kind of pissed off the wrong people I
have problems I started seeing issues I
said no problem everything I wrote in
there I implemented in my own company
yes okay and one of the things was if
you go above and beyond I want you to
also own a piece of this company I don't
want it to be just I own 100 the company
you don't yeah so what happened next
thing you know XYZ guy hits it you got
point three percent next one point eight
percent boom you own one percent the
company you own point six percent the
company you own point eight percent the
company the day the company sold
do you know how many vice presidents we
lost zero everybody stuck around because
everybody every one of our vice
presidents presidents own the piece of
the company some people don't like that
because they want to check but when I'm
selling let me tell you what I told the
buyers
I said hey I got some news for you
what's that
so you know typically your fear is
probably what you're thinking about
let's talk about it because I know you
may not ask me I want to talk about it
your fear is when we sell these guys are
going to leave and do the same thing yes
that is a fear valid fear let me tell
you what happens
here's our top 100 earners out of the
top 100 earners 70 of them have equity
in the company
and out of our top 50 earners some 98
percent of them or 96 percent of them
are rolling their entire stocks they're
not selling they're rolling wow they're
like they're rolling everyone's rolling
where's the fear of sound like a
no-brainer this much because they
believed in that company and the vision
of what we're going next so when you
give Equity they're grateful you're also
not getting them getting them to think
about becoming a competitor to you now
and to get an exit one of our guys I'll
never forget this guy was my boss one of
the guys I reported to at 23 years old
I was a direct competitor when I left
and started a company he's not supposed
to meet with me he was so afraid he
meets me at rafi's place he's dressed up
with a hat and glasses and a hoodie so
nobody sees him I said what are you
afraid of says I can't be seen with you
bro all I do we go back 10 years as I
know but if they know I met with you I
said relax I said look you're going to
get Equity he says what does equity mean
I said trust me you're going to be glad
you got Equity anyways the day we sold
the company a year prior to that he had
retired
when the check hit his bank account it
was a seven figure check this guy's
never seen money like this in his life
he's made 100 Grand a year wow when the
million dollar check at his bank account
he's in the sauna naked Colony crime I
know this is a crazy place
he's calling me crazy
what is this yeah I said I told you
Equity works is I never believed this
was gonna happen he said tears it's a
great experience awesome obviously it's
great when my wife and I when we got the
money and when you make a million 100
000 it's cool a million is really cool
10 million is breathing room at 10
million you're gonna breathe yeah at a
couple hundred million now it's kind of
like hey man we can really play ball and
maybe get to the next level the zero
year but
when your guys get checks it's it's very
emotional yeah when your guys gets
checks yeah because it's like I gave you
the promise you were loyal to me I
salute you for your loyalty here's a
check to it's a very unique feeling of
founder experiences with their people
that went above and beyond
foreign